I'm going to take you through the
process of amending a soil in place the
process we call scoop and dump here you
can see students spreading about four to
six inches of good quality compost on a
compacted soil area actually three bios
whales which connected as you can see
the depression there
once the compost is spread
we come in with a
backhoe which you'll see now right there
is back on the bucket is going down
about 15 to 18 inches scooping the
compost and the soil up in the air and
then dumping it back on the ground hence
scoop and dump
we have the backhoe working its way out
of the area so it doesn't drive on areas
that just have been amended
it's quite rough but we get seams of
compost
in between the clods of compacted soil
here you can see the area that's now
been completely scooped and dumped and
the plants are ready to be placed we
have a design which we had
decided on what to what to plant
beforehand so we're just going to be
implementing that process students
placing plants mostly shrubs in this
area
um
both B and B and containerized plants
and then they plant them
given the spacing that we had previously
decided upon and after they're in the
ground we mulch with two to three inches
of shredded bark mulch and the mulch is
really of course it gives a visual
appeal but it also adds a lot to the
soil so you can see the tire area mulch
this is probably the end of April 2014.
and uh
a few plants have started to pop but
mostly things are still a bit dormant
so this is September now you're looking
at that same year and you can see
there's quite a lot of plant growth uh
from what we had originally plants are
really taking off in the soil that has
been prepared for them
we're looking for canopy closure which
is where you have leaves touching leaves
of other plants so to reduce the amount
of light incidence and thus the amount
of weed growth so we don't expect this
to happen right away here's uh
July of next year and we're getting
quite a bit of growth so we're getting
close to canopy closure not quite there
but a lot of vigorous plant growth
because of the way we prepared the soil
this is catching rain water or storm
water from a parking lot which is the
purpose of this particular
area
so now we're at two years after planting
and we're really pretty much 90 percent
or greater of canopy closure
where you see leaves of all the
different shrubs touching each other
reduce the amount of light that gets the
soil and encourages weed growth the only
issue is we would always have to deal
with the edges of uh where you can't
actually have plants growing right over
that
but the weed growth is much reduced and
gives an easier way of maintaining such
a complex planting and the plants are
growing really well in the soil that we
prepared